faut-il redouter le chikungunya la
direction générale de la santé a demandé
une surveillance renforcée dans le
département du var
la présence du moustique potentiellement
porteurs du virus il a été établi
attention le virus lui même n'a pas été
détecté mais des actions de prévention
et d'information ont commencé sur place
olivier théron virgilia d'eau ce
technicien de lagence de démoustication
pose un piège
il s'agit de capturer des larves de
moustique tigre dans ce cimetière de
sainte maxime
un premier foyer a été mise au jour raji
positif typiquement le genre d'endroit
où le moustique aedes albopictus aime se
développer aedes albopictus dit le tigre
à cause de ses rayures et de sa voracité
continue sa migration vers l'ouest il
est arrivé par l'italie en 2005 il a
colonisé les alpes-maritimes et il s'est
installé dans le var depuis cet été il
est arrivé ici parce qu'on appelle un
transport passif en voiture en train
lors de déménagements dans des soucoupes
les gens transportent en fait foi des
larves soit des adultes qui rendent dans
des voitures et ressorte la seule façon
de lutter contre le moustique tigre
cette d'éliminer les eaux stagnantes en
ville et dans les jardins à sainte
maxime
même si le tigre est encore discret
certains ont déjà pris des mesures
donc à vous avez changé votre votre
façon d'arroser les projets supprimer
l'âge et supprimer la coupelle d'accord
de manière à ce que ça stagne pour
l'autre et si vous nous dites qu'il faut
vider les coupelles envie de râler
couper un plan d'alerté a été mis en
place par la direction générale de la
santé
le moustique tigre peut être vecteur du
virus du chikungunya aucune raison de
s'affoler en france le virus n'est pas
présent mme azila contaminé ces
dernières semaines 170 personnes à
ravenne en italie